let's talk about China yeah I got this
meme guys I got this meme um it's
actually just a news article technically
the truth China's State media mocked the
U.S withdrawing Afghanistan saying the
Taliban takeover was quote more smooth
than the presidential transition into
the U.S that's true I just got to say uh
in terms of roasting and trolling China
wow that's an Emmy right there they uh
that's a smack in the face to the U.S
that's a good troll it's kind of it's
kind of sad though isn't it they're
right I mean American domestically
they're right for domestic news media it
gets worse in a statement from the
global times which is Chinese State
media basically the mouthpiece of the
Chinese Communist Party from what
happened in Afghanistan those in Taiwan
should perceive that once a war breaks
out in the Straits the Island's defense
will collapse in hours and the U.S
military won't come to help as a result
the DPP will quickly surrender China
didn't say if War breaks out they said
when it breaks out once I'm sorry once a
war breaks out there you go once the war
breaks out
so I'm I'm asking you again what I asked
earlier who in the U.S has the appetite
who has in which political party which
force which machine sort of you know
whether Republicans Democrats activists
uh uh media which which uh I'm
think tanks which institution in the US
has patience for Wars to protect other
countries and especially especially when
there's so many people in the US again
institutions in the U.S who didn't have
even who didn't have the appetite to
take on China even on trade
or to take an even European trade I mean
you have people here who will tell you
that if the EU has a 10 percent tariffs
on products coming in from the US to
Europe
we shouldn't have the same we shouldn't
you know so so people don't even know
what nobody wants to work no no but it's
worse people aren't even willing to put
up a fight on tariffs to protect jobs
and the economy in the U.S right right
who's gonna who's gonna say yeah I think
we should we need to defend Taiwan and I
think China sees that it's not just that
uh the U.S the government propped up by
the U.S collapsed I think China is aware
of
uh the U.S not having the appetite yeah
it happens the apathy of the American
people War weariness there's a
difference between
war in Afghanistan and uh and Taiwan we
I think Afghanistan's a huge mistake we
it was it was just stupid Iraq was
stupid a lot of things the US does in
the Middle East are very very stupid
Taiwan is an ally and we have allies in
uh southeast Asia and um in the Pacific
and it's a huge threat if China starts
attacking them and the U.S would need to
defend them however I don't think
anybody you're right has an appetite for
war but I don't think you need to have
an effect for war if you have a
president and administration strong
enough to just set that boundary that
can't be crossed and I certainly think
as I stated with the Taliban and what
we're seeing now you look at the
economic crisis you look at the what did
Joe Biden just do he increased uh uh
um food benefit payments yeah snap uh
food stamps
which says two things one more more
money being given out which is already
bad for the escalating inflation and two
it shows that inflation on food is here
to stay now they've got to increase it
and they're saying it's because they
want to make sure people get more
nutrients okay well then you're just
giving more free free money away so
people are going to be less incentivized
to work you you need to tell me I mean
the Taliban certainly noticed the
weakness of the body Administration but
you take a look at what China knows
China's engaged in cyber warfare they
got a great intelligence they are they
are very powerful and they're looking at
this and they know exactly what they can
and can't do and right now I think this
statement they're pointing out they're
not joking they're not saber this is not
meant to intimidate uh or make it or or
you know tell the US ha we're coming
they're saying no we're going to do it
and no one's going to stop us because
Americans are I mean look look at the
the way China cracked down on Hong Kong
and
I don't think anyone you know speaks up
or wants to do anything about it
the reason for it I don't know this is
this is how it is maybe it is because of
the US was so so heavily involved in
these two countries over the last two
decades at a steep cost to the country
in terms of
uh um
soldiers dying or being wounded and you
have families suffering and people don't
even know to what end to to accomplish
what so people just become tired it's
like a game almost yeah and I think and
I think
um
I think there's also a different level
of what you know different level of
patriotism
today versus many years ago uh I think
this also plays into
a lot of it I think uh generation or two
ago people were more willing
to fight for the country I think today
you have it less what's the reason I
don't know but I think I think this is a
factor so if people don't have the
appetite to fight for their country I'm
not saying what people you know tweeting
for their country people think that's
considered fighting you know standing up
to Trump tweeting for the country resist
uh you know then why would they why
would they want to be involved in Taiwan
and China I don't know that's that's why
I wonder we asked this question of a lot
of people you know is is the the culture
War a product of America's enemies
sewing divisions online I mean we we
heard all the reports of you know
Russian interference and how Russia had
been running different sides of the
culture War so the impact was
microscopic first and foremost but what
they would do is these these uh internet
trolls would create a black lives matter
Facebook page and then like an
anti-black lives matter page and then
they would organize protests around each
other so that those conflicts Could
Happen granted it doesn't seem like they
had a tremendous impact but when I look
at what's happening in the U.S the I
mean how about this what was it Colin
Kaepernick I think complained about the
American flag shoe and they banned it
yep that that is one of the most
psychotic and insane things I've ever
heard one of the one of the symbols of
the founding of this country when you
lose that cohesion you fall apart and
now look at where we are you look at
what Afghanistan no no social cohesion
no national identity and they just
collapse no cultural identity except for
the Taliban of course and they sweep in
like that because they've got a passion
for their cause now you look what's
happening with the 1619 project Wellness
critical race applied principles and you
have an entire faction of people who
don't like this country I'll tell you
this
I think it was it was a Jimmy Fallon
he did uh was it Fallon he did a census
data came out and it shows that for the
first time the white population has
shrunk and the audience starts busting
out clapping and cheering and then he
looks like why are you like what I
didn't watch the whole show but I saw
that clip and it was why were they
clapping for that I mean probably
probably 80 of the audience was what no
right like you think about the
self-destructive nature of these these
white
establishment liberal type personalities
but I think a lot of the conversations
um in this in this Arena I think is also
people are just bored out of their mind
and they're looking for for reason to
belong some somewhere someplace to
accomplish like why not go help a local
soup kitchen and they get involved in
stupidity is like you're not you're not
changing anything and then they sit
there in a clap you're clapping for what
it's it's it's strange but why how about
we all agree that China is a major
threat and we can rally around defending
you know the people of Taiwan or
standing up for them or having having a
cohesive
message of you know we will defend our
allies instead it's just
I don't know man ragging on People based
on their race or gender or just
self-loathing and hating themselves I
I'm not I think I think many people who
uh you know supposedly are
self-loathing as based on their racial
or ethnic background I think a lot of it
is not real I think they they there's
it's just a genre to get retweets to get
attention I mean it's it's not it's not
legit I mean probably 95 you know in the
past at least 95 percent people in the
US would live in communities that
reflect their own ethnicity or culture
or marry into families that fit the
culture and ethnicity so a lot of these
a lot of these posts and and videos and
articles I think is just people looking
for attention to be uh relevant they
want to get along on the bandwagon of
something
um but but the point is it shows that we
have nothing that unifies us
it's it's it's what unifies US is our
hatred for each other in this country
and so you have you have the culture War
the culture War left and the culture War
right and there's some overlapping weird
it's like we should draw a map so maybe
maybe you know maybe that's the
byproduct of having peace and prosperity
you don't have the worries and concerns
that we do though we have we have China
Russia but then but then but then we are
so Protestant these days that people uh
would take positions on foreign policy
based on which president can get more
credit or more hits over the head you
know figuratively speaking so it's what
I'm saying is uh going back to the 70s
and the 80s even you know people were
scared from the USSR at the time people
people had I think the minds of people
were busy with
um with the well-being of the US
but I think we we live uh for a
generation already in a in a situation
where there's a lot of peace and a lot
of prosperity okay fine I mean there's
been 911 and other stuff but relatively
speaking it's not people don't wake up
every day they have this big Russian
monster the big ussrp they tried yeah
but but people don't feel people don't
feel it this way the last 20 30 years so
you have a a whole generation Our
Generation being Grays spoiled brats and
we have the world at our fingertips and
then we see people writing interesting
articles and they get the retweets and
the likes and I get invited on TV and
they want in on it yeah um it's it's a
shame because so much of this energy can
be used
can be used on bringing people together
on concerns that are legitimate concerns
about
um
you take the issue take the issue of you
know please please brutality that's very
popular in the liberal field I think at
this this day and age I think a lot of
people would admit that there are
reforms that can be had in law
enforcement but if you make everything a
racial issue when there are multiple
incidents of police officers who are
minority physically abusing fellow
minorities then obviously the issue of
the issues of of challenges and law
enforcement is not exclusively or not
only or not primarily race-based so why
are you making it about race when
I think there needs to be some overall
who gets hired how they're hired the
training I mean your standard police
officer again I'm not I'm not picking on
police officers as the individual
talking about the training
they can sometimes pull over someone in
the afternoon sitting there with a
family it's it's four o'clock in the
afternoon
it's a family family man if you will and
the tone is if you just stopped is a a
terror suspect it's like everyone is
dealt with as if they are a suspect of
something something is wrong with the
training so something is wrong with
training a police officer that they can
go this crazy this quick against a
person who is otherwise a civilian and
then there's also a lack of
accountability
and law enforcement
um I'm not saying now the world of blue
silence uh whatever I was called it's
just you know it's who who is
accountable to whom
so and so a lot of these things I think
lead to to challenges and how to police
a community so rather than people coming
together law enforcement and civilians
people from old backgrounds to to pass
laws and rules how to make things better
the whole conversation gets hijacked
about race and once you do that you lose
half the country and that's why let me
just wrap it up for this and that's why
we're debating today in 2021 the same
issues of police brutality that we did
20 30 years ago without much change
I think we're missing
uh cohesive suffering as a society or
suffering or worry or concern such as
you had with Russia 34 years helped a
lot like fear and worry is helpful but
real suffering you can is undeniable
like if if I'm suffering and the police
officer both suffering because we're
both looking for food I'm like okay
we're both in a bad place you have it a
little worse because you've got to go
fight guys for a living but at least we
can get we can agree we're both
suffering and we have a shared Focus as
a species to get food but now that's
completely in the United States there's
no suffering my I have to induce it on
myself psychedelics make you suffer
correct even even even basic crime rates
however bad things are the last 12
months if you want to compare to to the
1990s I mean 20 25 years ago it's
beautiful again God forbid you know any
single person getting attacked or I'm
not speaking about the individual victim
but again as a society
is generally more safer to go out on
this people have less worry as they had
20 40 years ago I think people just
going crazy no I think I'm crazy I think
you got to rephrase it people have less
to worry about but they're more worried
than ever
okay it's because because we we all have
our exactly as uh so someone just you
know text me I shouldn't use my phone
while I'm on the show you know it's that
bad this is this is uh the thing about
police brutality that I've brought up
several times the reason they're such a
hyper focus on it is because it plays
well for social media people know that
if they post these videos if they
complain about it they'll get clicks
retweets and followers so they they
played into it it's shock content it's
violent content and it's I'm okay with
all of that in other words I understand
the the drive that people have uh you
know to get what I'm saying is the only
thing they'll see is that they don't
mean okay in other words they don't want
to see a fix or solution and no no no no
no no no you got a 10 year old kid he
goes on Facebook for the first time and
50 adults are sharing police brutality
for for retweets for shares that kid
will see nothing but Place brutality Ten
Years Later say they're born in 2010 or
let's say they're born in 2000 they're
10 years old in 2010 they get on Twitter
or whatever they're not supposed they're
too young they can do anyway they see
endless streams of police brutality for
a decade then they're 20 going Why Won't
Anyone do anything about this and it's
like bro turn off the phone and go
outside it's not happening it happens
it's bad when it does it's a valid point
in other words the the the the the
reality becomes misconstrued it becomes
it becomes uh all messed up things are
not sometimes as bad as people think as
it is as you said
um you know the video the videos of a
police officer you know playing
basketball with a local uh with a couple
of kids that's not going to get so much
attention as a police officer doing
something bad right and but against okay
I was gonna say that there's there's
similar criticism to go to uh in today's
sense with antifa violence and BLM
rights and stuff uh footage that gets
recycled over and over and over again
because it plays well but I would say
that tendency is more the exception and
not the rule because the media mostly
ignores it and it doesn't play well it
doesn't play with him you know there's
this old joke you have I don't know how
many flights in the area and at any
given time seven thousand whatever all
those flights landing you're not gonna
have a reporter well look there's
another plane landing right another plan
you have one plane even the three people
on it you know crashing down on the
freeway right exactly it's going to
become national news that's how humans
are right so so the issue is someone
could share a video video of antifa and
it'll play well with some people who are
like this is bad but police brutality
makes everyone even conservatives get
angry so if you look at like George
Floyd for instance you know you get
people like Ben Shapiro and Sean Hannity
coming up being like weird we are upset
by this correct so I'm not I don't have
a problem please brutality being a
discussion because I think there are
reforms to be had what I'm saying is
that the the the the solution of it I
think a couple uh six weeks ago there
were a couple of police officers who
beat up a child a teenager or what have
you in a retail store
um I think two of the officers at a
minimum were minority officers and the
the victim was awesome it wasn't even a
story
so that's the the
what I'm trying to tell what I'm trying
to say is this
I understand the the the the shock value
you know why it becomes news but I'm I'm
also saying that a lot of times people
don't want to have real solutions of
course they want to fit into into a
certain narrative a certain agenda for
whatever reason and therefore things
don't get corrected such as so many
issues on police brutality because I
think some of the core causes are not
addressed who gets hired sometimes
crazies get hired into law enforcement
complete clouds get hired and you don't
have a good screening process and then
the training sometimes is is insane and
then sometimes a lack of oversight so if
if you don't address any of these core
issues and you and you only focus let's
say on Race there's so many of these
incidents will not get fixed so going
back to what I said a minute ago and as
you said it correctly there isn't a
shared suffering a shared worry
and so people have extra time on their
mind how how can I how can I become busy
and then you have a cause have a cause
and then you have social media and you
see you know certain things play well
you want to get along on it and you can
make a lot of money spreading negative
information you get very famous very
quickly on the internet because that
stuff spreads like wildfire negative
information or information that's very
popular at the time it's like if you
notice in institutional media
uh you know I have it sometimes in in
the private practice
um when I when clients retain me and I
need to work with them on on media
outreach it's like
if you want to pitch a story to a
reporter if if no other journalist
picked that up that that journal is
going to say no I I don't know why why
will I do it and sometimes if one person
has it everyone has it so people like to
people like to jump on imperative
abandoning it's an impossible problem to
solve you know mentioning the negative
money cycle the night I'm sorry the
negative news cycle and the money made
because I mean what are we doing we're
we're going on a show we're saying oh
look at what's happened here and that's
bad and this is bad and we're it's
almost kind of uh
it's it's kind of a it's a recursive
Loop of us being like people sharing
negative information on the Internet is
is bad it's like literally doing that in
this in the space of doing it now here's
the point I'm making what would happen
if we decided to stop talking about the
things we thought were were bad and and
we stopped talking about the news and
these negative things then you would
have more and more bad things happen
because people wouldn't be paying
attention and and would be allowed to
fester and grow so I think if you go to
any person even a black lives matter
activist who sang police brutality 24 7.
well they're going to be like I'm not
doing anything wrong I'm not doing this
because I want to be rich I'm doing it
this place for tally is a problem and
then when you're like yeah but when you
have a hundred thousand people posting
police brutality over and over and over
and kids don't see anything else it's
making them lose their minds
I don't know how you solve for that
problem people are allowed to be
passionate and fight for what they
believe in I think there's a balance of
um you too much talking about problems
creates more problems too not enough
talking about problems creates more
problems because they're not being
addressed so you want to address them
and then solve them and then not address
them anymore uh unless there's still a
problem and the solution didn't work and
then you got to readdress them and
address a new solution about the
equation problem without a solution is
basically like the biggest but the
bigger problem is again let's talk about
a problem is that people sometimes don't
want a solution outside of a set
narrative right I think that's more
destructive than people talking about
problems I love that then we can debate
the solution as opposed to debating we
know what the problem is yeah a lot of
times but the people don't want to have
uh uh people don't want to debate the
solution thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time